dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on AFA here we have
had plenty of episodes about fluid
simulations so how about some tasty soft
body dynamics for today
soft body dynamics basically means
computing what happens when we smash
together different deformable objects
examples include folding sheets playing
around with noodles or torturing
armadillos I think this is a nice and
representative showcase of the immense
joys of computer graphics research the
key to real-time physically-based
simulations is parallelism parallelism
means that we have many of the same
units working together in harmony
imagine if we had to assign 50 people to
work together to make a coffee in the
same kitchen as you may imagine they
would trip over each other and the
result would be chaos not productivity
such a process would not scale favorably
because as we would add more people
after around 3 or 4 the productivity
would not increase but drop
significantly you can often hear a
similar example of nine pregnant women
not being able to give birth to a baby
in one month for better scaling we have
to subdivide a bigger task into small
tasks in a way that these people can
work independently the more
independently they can work the better
the productivity will scale as we add
more people in software engineering
these virtual people we like to call
threads or compute units as of 2016 mid
tier processors are equipped with four
to eight logical cores and for a video
card we typically have compute units in
the order of hundreds so if we wish to
develop efficient algorithms we have to
make sure that these big simulation
tasks are subdivided in a way so that
these threads are not tripping over each
other and the big contribution of this
piece of work is a technique to
distribute the computation tasks to
these compute units in a way that they
are working on independent chunks of the
problem this is achieved via using graph
coloring which is a technique typically
used for designing seating plans exam
timetabling solving Sudoku puzzles
similar assignment tasks it not only
works in an absolutely spectacular
manner but graph theory is an immensely
beautiful subfield of mathematics so
additional style points to the authors
the technique produces remarkably
realistic animations and requires only
15 milliseconds per frame which means
that this technique can render over 60
frames per second comfortably and the
other most important factor is that this
technique is also stable meaning that it
offers an appropriate solution even when
many other techniques fail to deliver
thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time
you